the eu to be working sort of as the
leader on this as opposed to nato
leading the charge as the relationship
goes to russia the negotiations go
would the us be comfortable with the eu
leading those direct conversations as
opposed to nato being the lead well
there are a range of formats and forums
that uh
have been ongoing right including
conversations through nato including
conversations through the osce i know
that there are conversations that are
happening uh
through the normandy format that are
happening today in paris and we
certainly support international efforts
that that take place in a range of
forums obviously nato is a forum that uh
we work with and coordinate with our
partners as it relates to
military support and how we're going to
provide assurances to eastern flank
countries so that's certainly the
appropriate form for that but again
there's a range of forums just to
discuss de-escalation negotiation
including the normandy format that's
taking place today go ahead thank you a
question about immigration sure
why is it that large numbers of single
adult men are being released into the
united states just hours after being
apprehended at the southern border
well i'm not sure the specifics of what
you're referring to peter what i can
tell you in terms of what our policy is
and how we're approaching the border is
that we continue to be under title 42 uh
migrants who cannot be expelled under
tidy title 42 are placed into
immigration proceedings and one of those
avenues could be placement in an
alternative to detention program in the
interior of the united states sometimes
that means moving migrants to other
parts of the united states to move to
different detention facilities where
they wait for next steps in the
immigration process such as the court
hearing and are required to check in
with the local ice
office so that is something certainly
something that is happening out there in
the country and is consistent with our
policy you mentioned that they're
supposed to check in at a local ice
office but we know that just between
march and august which is a very small
sample size dhs says more than 47 000 of
these migrants that were given
notices to report did not show up so why
let them into the u.s unsupervised in
the first place well again we have a
stringent uh protocols and processes
that we implement here
that includes expelling
individuals who come in under title 42
given we are still in a global pandemic
and includes those who are do not show
up will be subject to the repercussions
of that so that is the policy we're
implementing uh from our homeland
security department okay uh on ukraine
president biden met with putin in person
in june in geneva and afterwards he came
out he said that the two of them arrived
at a conclusion he said it's clearly not
in anybody's interest your countries are
mine for us to be in a situation where
we're in a new
cold war and i truly believe he thinks
that he understands that
has the president changed his opinion
about what putin thinks
how are you suggesting we're in a new
cold war
i'm just asking it seems like the
president
thought in june that things were going
to be good and right now things are not
looking good i don't actually think
that's at all what the president said he
gave an extensive press conference where
he conveyed it wouldn't happen overnight
and that there was work that we could do
together uh and that is something that
that's how you approach a diplomatic
relationship you are vocal there are
consequences when you disagree and when
you have strong concerns and you've seen
us implement those you still look for
places and areas where you can work
together that remains how we're working
with russia okay there's a buzzfeed
report now suggesting that the ukrainian
government is upset the u.s pulled
citizens out of ukraine before many
other countries did and this report says
that a close a source close to the
ukrainian president uh thinks those
americans are safer in kiev than in los
angeles what do you make of that well
we're always going to make decisions
that are in the security interests of uh
people who are serving as diplomats
around the world and we have assessments
that are made by the state department
hence the decision and the announcement
made uh over the last couple of days and
the fact that we put in a level four
advisory back in october conveying very
clearly to americans they should leave
ukraine uh look i will let others assess
but there are a hundred thousand troops
russian troops on the border of ukraine
and no clarity that the leader of russia
doesn't intend to invade that sounds
pretty dangerous to me i would also say
that the ukrainian leaders have welcomed
the security assistance and they've even
met us at the airport that we have been
providing over the course of the last
several days so that seems to be
contradicting that assessment okay and
the last one the secretary of state a
few days ago tweeted
i hashtag
stand with ukraine
has that ever worked
at stopping an authoritarian regime from
doing anything a hashtag
i will have to say that unlike the last
administration we don't think twitter is
the only means of engaging or
negotiating or discussing important
topics but it is important for us to
convey uh to the ukrainian people who do
view
commentary through a range of forums i
don't know how many are fox news
watchers maybe some of them um and
including social media that we stand
with them we support them uh and that
includes in their efforts to protect the
sovereignty of their country uh go ahead
uh you mentioned the visit about the
german chance
not yet hopefully we'll have one soon
tonight and then put it back to russia
u.s is uh
in talks with other countries to deal
with potential shortages and gas
supplies can you speak to that a little
bit in particular
what requests you've made of qatar and
whether they have responded about
whether they would be able to step in
and fill any shortfalls should that
happen in the case of the problem sure
so it's uh our approach is not about any
one country or any individual entity
we're engaging with a range of countries
and partners uh to discuss what we
what could be shortages um so i'm not
going to get into any specifics of what
any conversations entail they can
certainly speak for themselves um but
what i can give you an update on is that
a disruption of course in physical
energy supplies transiting transiting
ukraine would most acutely uh affect
natural gas markets in europe and so
we're engaging our european allies to
coordinate response planning including
how to deploy their existing energy
stockpiles that's part of it but we've
also been working to identify additional
volumes of non-russian natural gas from
north africa and the middle east asia
and the united states we're in
discussion with major natural gas
producers around the globe to understand
their capacity and willingness to
temporarily surge natural gas output and
to allocate these volumes to european
buyers and we're also engaging with
major buyers and suppliers of lng to
ensure flexibility in existing contracts
and storage is managed and enables
diversion to europe so we are of course
preparing as we are in a lot of other
areas a range of contingencies um should
there be a disruption for a range of
reasons to natural gas i would also note
that natural gas markets are very
regional by nature uh given constraints
on how much can be exported so any
reduction in russian exports of natural
gas to europe would have a minimal
impact on u.s prices that's what our
anticipation would be
on
qatar specifically there's some
there's a belief that they've sort of
allocated their production right now
which is running it more or less full
capacity to asia have you had any
feedback from that country i'm just not
going to speak for any individual
country or any individual diplomatic
conversations at this point in time
that's why i said that it's about it's
not based on our approach and strategy
is not based on one one any one
individual country or entity it's a
broad approach that includes engagement
with europeans as well as uh as
suppliers in north africa and middle
east asia and in the us
can you say you know last week was when
the administration began to sort of
ratchet up warnings that an invasion
could be imminent to happen at any time
this week where
can you say how if at all the
president's view has changed about the
risk is it the same is it
getting worse
when we said it was imminent it remains
imminent uh but again we can't make a
prediction of what decision president
putin will make we're still engaged in
diplomatic discussions and negotiations
element of the last week has changed the
president's view one way or the other on
that well imminent has a pretty
intense meaning doesn't it okay it's
still the belief that it is correct
thank you yes go ahead
the kremlin is using the u.s
announcement of putting 8 500 troops on
alert to say that it's the u.s that is
fueling this conflict
the white house's reaction to that
well i would say that our
commitment to our nato partners and
allies is ironclad if you go back to 9
11 the only the first time that article
5 was
invoked it was in defense of the united
states and we take our commitment to our
eastern flank partners nato allies very
seriously
but what is important to note is that
the aggressive behavior here is on the
part of the russians this is a defensive
alliance not an offensive alliance and
what we're doing here is uh not making a
decision as has been clear by nato
partners and by the president or members
of our national security team to deploy
but thus just to be ready and we have a
responsibility to do that so that people
who might be deployed can tell their
family members it's a shorter period of
time um and uh to be uh to be ready to
to uh deliver on our commitment to our
nato partners can you clarify are those
8 500 troops who are now
at the ready as you said are they
already based in europe
you were banned the united states europe
and the united states and did nato
request that the us put them on the
ready or is that a us author it's a
conversation with nato so a
collaborative discussion and a follow-up
on peter's question about ukraine
are there direct questions or excuse me
direct contacts with ukraine right now
to away their concerns that the u.s was
acting preemptively to or
too early too soon to take personnel out
of the country uh so yeah we are in
constant contact with ukrainians um to
reiterate our support uh to convey uh
updates on shipments of supplies
military equipment something that's been
happening over the last several days uh
our national security adviser jake
sullivan has spoken with his counterpart
at least eight times over the past a few
weeks and u.s officials at the state
department defense department across our
government continue to work in close
coordination on a daily basis with
ukrainian officials secretary blinken as
you know was in ukraine last week and he
called his ukrainian counterpart to read
out his meeting with russian foreign
minister lavrov so we have been in
constant and close contact with
ukrainians
leaders at a range of levels as well as
with our european
partners last week
senator mcconnell gave you some unusual
praise the white house today about its
preparations for ukraine saying that it
looked like the white house was prepared
to act before an incursion and not after
do you know what steps he was referring
to there is that just the the troop
deployment and b were you pleased to
hear
some positive words from senator
mcconnell
well yes of course we were i mean look i
think um abiding by our um article five
commitments um standing up for the
territorial sovereignty of ukraine
making clear that one country should not
be able to invade and take over
territory from another country that's
not just a democratic belief or a
republican belief that's central to who
we are as a country and who leaders like
leader mcconnell or senator mcconnell
like president biden have that's what
their belief has been for many decades
so we certainly welcome that i would
note there's there was a bipartisan
delegation uh we have uh had it all done
a lot of briefings uh from leaders uh in
the administration with uh hill leaders
those will continue uh as well and what
was the second part what was he was
referring to i i certainly would would
point you to him i would say that we
obviously have taken a number of steps
in recent weeks including very close
coordination more than 100 engagements
with european partners
staying in close contact with the
ukrainians
obviously uh taking steps including
sanctions last week making clear that we
are going to have troops at the ready to
support uh nato efforts uh so i would
point you to him but we have been taking
ever and even uh noting false flag
operations and kind of calling out
propaganda but i would point you to him
or his team on any specifics he was
referring to go ahead republican
lawmakers in florida are advancing a
bill that would borrow the state from
doing business with companies that
transport undocumented migrants into the
state does the white house have a
response to this legislation uh i am not
familiar with the specifics of the
legislation i i can check with our team
and see
uh go ahead i'll start with a question
on behalf of a reporter who can't be in
the room today his name is pablo
manriquez outlet is called futuro media
and he asks what unilateral authority is
the president willing to exercise for
immigrant relief that has not been tried
yet
for immigration reform or relief or well
i would say um
we're going to have to keep trying some
of the measures that we have we have
been working on to date you know the
president put forward uh proposed an
immigration bill a comprehensive
immigration bill and his first day in
office we've obviously continued to work
with leaders in the senate to try to
push that forward including trying to
work to have components included in the
president's bill back better agenda
we're going to continue to work to not
only instill and implement safer
security measures but also more humane
measures with how
people are treated how children are
treated and we're also going to work
continue to work and double redouble our
efforts to address root causes so we're
going to continue to approach this from
many friends pablo also asks is the
president willing to reallocate unused
green cards and apply them to immigrants
waiting in decades-long green card
backlogs
well we have uh reformed to the system
uh green card system is certainly
something we've talked about as a part
of immigration reform uh i can check and
see if there's anything we can do
unilaterally on that front back on you
created russia can you give us a status
report on the written response to moscow
when can we expect it and will it be
made public sure um i don't have an
exact timing update of course that would
be um led by our secretary of state and
our diplomatic team who have been
closely engaging in these efforts
in terms of whether or not it would be
public i would note that typically it's
not
typically a paper paper that is part of
negotiations or discussions if you look
at the iran nuclear deal or you look at
any treaty not that this is a treaty but
just as a point of comparison
negotiations or discussions uh is
typically not made public um it's a part
of the diplomatic process and has been
used by our diplomats for many decades
is the president involved in the
crafting of the response
the president certainly engages is
briefed by and uh approves every
component of our response and our
efforts in this uh in this process
one of the criticisms that some fellow
democrats have been voicing in the press
uh recently is that the president has
surrounded himself with four of loyal
aides who've been with him for many
years and increasingly these democrats
are publicly saying that these aides
have left the president ill-served are
you aware of a response from the
president to those criticisms
uh in terms of what well uh there was a
the democratic senator quoted today in
the newspaper that said that sometimes
the boxcars
are empty um you know you know that
senator manchin has publicly i was i
didn't really even understand that quote
just to be honest but um here's what i
would say and i think i know what you're
getting at steve so let me try to answer
your question um
i am new to president uh biden's orbit
um i've only been working for him since
i
joined the administration during the
transition and then joined in this role
here that i'm still in today
what i have found is that
i see him on a daily basis sometimes
multiple times a day
he asks me consistently what i think and
by the people who have been surrounding
him for some time whether that's ron
clayne or steve roshetti or others
they've certainly encouraged and
supported that relationship and
engagement what i've seen the president
do and i know this isn't what everybody
has visibility into so i guess that's
why i'm sharing this level of detail is
if you're in a meeting with him and
you're having a conversation if you
don't know the answer he wants more
information he picks up the phone and he
calls the person he thinks does
sometimes that's ron plain sometimes
that's susan rice sometimes it's brian
diese sometimes it's louisa terrell
that's how the president operates and
that effort to uh really empower team
team members and have that direct
relationship with the president is
something that uh that's been my
experience to date
go ahead thanks
just back to your comment about white
house outreach on the hill yeah can you
confirm the white house is holding two
classifieds yeah sure and let me and let
me give you a little bit more uh detail
on that because i think i have that here
too
so these these briefings are led of
course by um the state department and
defense departments uh but today uh we
are providing two additional classified
bipartisan briefings for house and
senate leadership and committee staff
they'll be providing updates on recent
developments with ukraine and russia and
the state of play
we're also working on all members
briefings for the house and the senate
in the coming days in the last week
alone secretary blinken and deputy
secretary sherman have spoken to nearly
20 members with additional engagements
planned this week and since december
we've had dozens of engagements with
congress on ukraine and russia including
uh two by president biden including one
on december 7th with big four uh with
the big four uh a january 19th virtual
meeting with codell uh members um six
briefings from national security adviser
sullivan to bipartisan members of the
house and senate including leadership
and national security committee chairs
and ranking members nine interagency
briefings for bipartisan members of
national security committees eight
interagency briefings for bipartisan
hill staff including leadership
committee and personal staff and of
course an open hearing that toriya
newland participated in back in december
um so this is an ongoing process and we
will continue to provide regular
briefings some classified some not
moving forward
oh good um
is there any updates on the federal
website for testing that you can give us
on how many tests went out or how many
were requested sure i certainly
understand the question there has been a
great deal of interest um i don't have
an exact number i know that's something
we will be putting out let me check on
the status of that i know i've got to
wrap this up so let me just quickly try
to get to as many as i can i also wanted
to ask about the testing do you know at
this point how many of the tests that
you've already ordered have come in yet
i don't mean going out to the american
people that are in your stockpile and
also when you'll be signing contracts
for the other for the additional 500
million uh let me check on both of those
questions for you
i wanted to ask you um about yesterday
when you were talking about the
competition executive order um you were
saying about how the white house has met
100 of the deadlines in that order i
know a lot of those deadlines are for
writing plans to do things um in
different agencies sure can you talk
about what tangible results americans
will see in the next six months to a
year
out of all those different plans you've
met those deadlines but now people will
start to see the effect of them sure i
mean the president talked about this a
little bit yesterday but part of that
and i don't know exact timeline on it
because they all have different
implementation efforts but some tangible
things are being able to buy hearing
aids over the counter being able to take
some of your products and get them
repaired anywhere you want without
worrying about
that being a challenge
making sure we're taking steps to
address lack of competition that is out
there in a range of industries where
prices are going up so every agency is
writing different plans and i'm sure
they can detail and outline in more
specifics but i also barat from our nac
team has been one of the people leading
this effort and maybe i'll see if he can
come and give you guys all a more
comprehensive briefing okay todd last
one and then i got it you guys i think i
got together questions um some members
of congress have
been promoting this theory that the fbi
had at least one provocateur in the
january 6th mom
um can the white house say unequivocally
that there were no federal agents who
provoked illegal attacks well fbi
director ray has already said that the
fbi had no evidence of the spaceless
conspiracy and he would certainly know
um and last week we've seen a number of
house republicans
announcing billions of dollars worth of
infrastructure projects in their
districts
these are republicans who voted against
that bill
what does the white house have to say
about that we welcome their support for
the president's agenda and an agenda
that was supported by some republicans
not the majority and hopefully they'll
take the right vote to support their
communities and jobs job creation in the
future it will make them think twice
thanks everyone
i'm so sorry i got it you i think some
of you guys have to wrap so
oh you have time
oh sorry does it mean to cut it off so
dramatically go ahead does the white
house have any words of support for the
students in dc who are currently walking
out to protest lacks coping standards in
their schools
oh in dc and arlington
well look i i think that um we we
understand
um as a parent myself but i know these
students are are dealing with uh fears
that they have themselves about the fear
of going to a school a classroom a
workplace
where you don't feel safe that is one of
the reasons that we have been so
supportive and advocated for um for uh
for leaders and school leaders to follow
public health guidelines so um you know
that is the way to keep people safe uh
to ensure people can feel safe in their
school or their workplace and and
certainly we we support that
go ahead thank you thank you tomorrow
india is celebrating its 73rd republic
day
as the leader of world's oldest
democracy uh what is present by this
masses to the people of the world's
largest democrats
will we join india the world's largest
democracy in honoring republic day the
day that marks the adoption of india's
constitution as president biden said
when india's prime minister modi visited
the white house last september the
relationship between india and the
united states is destined to be stronger
closer and tighter and it can benefit
the whole world our partnership is
rooted in our shared responsibility to
uphold democratic values one more on
ukraine you know india has had a has is
having a very strong and historic
relationship with russia president putin
was recently in new delhi for his annual
summit meeting with prime minister modi
perhaps president biden also has a
strong friendship with prime minister
modi does doesn't matter think that
india in the our crimes
in his role can do some something with
both u.s and russia to de-escalate
the situation in ukraine
well we certainly welcome any efforts to
de-escalate and we are
in touch with a range of allies and
partners on this but i don't have any
specific uh conversations to read out
that relate to indian officials go ahead
linda go ahead oh sure so the president
has nothing on his schedule today aside
from the pdb can you shed any light on
on how he's spending his day
uh well let's see um this morning i
think he had some policy meetings also a
pdb meeting um he um later this
afternoon uh i think is doing some
remarks review there are some days that
we spend some time uh doing internal
meetings and discussions uh with policy
experts with policy leaders um and
that's that's what's happening today
he would say he doesn't have nearly
enough time and free time on his
schedule because it is packed no matter
whether people see him or not tomorrow
thursday is it a lot of time in this
situation
there will be certainly some time where
he'll be meeting with and engaging with
his national security team i'm certain
uh we have an event tomorrow on uh bill
back better where there'll be a number
of ceos here so that will be part of the
day tomorrow as well
sure forgive me it's sort of the
elephant the room um
many people in the country were talking
about it last night this morning
does the president regret saying what he
said about peter can you shed some light
if you haven't
had any conversations with him today
about what happened last night
well i i would say what's most important
and i it's peter's sitting here so this
is kind of a funny thing but uh the
press the president uh the president um
called peter and i he confirmed this so
this is only why i'm speaking to this
and if you have private conversations
with the president i will assure you i'm
not going to convey that on your behalf
but peter spoke to this the president
called him he conveyed uh to him that it
was nothing personal man and also
acknowledged that all of you are going
to ask him a range of questions uh so i
think that uh speaks for itself
uh thank you everyone hopefully i did
that justice
person familiar
okay
we only do on the record stuff here
peter thanks everyone have a good rest
of your day
um